what do you think is the meaning of this
whole thing we have here
uh
of human civilization of life on earth
but in general just life
what's the meaning of life
see
have you did you read uh nova scene yet
by james lovelock you're doing a lot of
really good book recommendations here i
haven't even finished this so i'm a huge
fraud yet again um but like really early
in the book um
he says this amazing thing like i feel
like everyone's so sad and cynical like
everyone's like the fermi paradox and
everyone i just keep hearing people
being like [ __ ] what if we're alone like
oh no ah like uh uh and i'm like okay
but like wait what if this is the
beginning
like in nova scene he says um
i'm this is not going to be a correct i
can't like memorize quotes but he says
something like um
uh
what if our consciousness
like right now like
this
is the universe waking up like what if
instead of discovering the universe this
is the universe
like this is the evolution
of the little literal universe herself
like we are not separate from the
universe like this is the universe
waking up this is the universe seeing
herself for the first time like this is
um the universe becoming conscious first
time and we're part of that yeah because
it's like we aren't
separate from the universe like like
this could be of like an incredibly
sacred moment and maybe like social
media and all these things the the stuff
where we're all getting connected
together like
maybe this these are the neurons
connecting of the like collective super
intelligence
that is
you know waking up the the yeah like
like you know it's like maybe instead of
something cynical or maybe if there's
something to discover like maybe this is
just
you know we're a blastocyst of of like
some incredible
kind of consciousness
or being and just like in the first
three years of life or for human
children we'll forget about all the
suffering that we're going through now i
think we'll probably forget about this i
mean probably
you know artificial intelligence
will eventually render us obsolete i
don't think they'll do it in a
malicious way but i think probably we
are very weak the sun is expanding like
i don't know like hopefully we can get
to mars but like we're pretty vulnerable
and i i you know like
i think we can coexist for a long time
with ai and we can also probably make
ourselves less vulnerable but
you know i just think um
consciousness sentence self-awareness
like i think this might be the single
greatest
like moment in
evolution ever and like maybe this is
you know
the big like the
true beginning of of life and we're just
we're we're the blue green algae or
we're like we're like the single-celled
organisms of something amazing the
universe awakens and this is this is it
yeah
well uh see you're an incredible person
you're a fascinating mind um you should
definitely do your friend liv
mentioned that you guys were thinking of
maybe talking i would love it if you uh
explored your mind in this kind of
medium more and more by doing a podcast
with her or just in any kind of way so
you're you're an awesome person it's an
honor to know you it's an honor to get
to sit down with you late at night which
is like
surreal um and i really enjoyed it thank
you for talking today yeah no i mean
huge honor i feel very underqualified to
be here but i'm a big fan i've been
listening to the podcast a lot and yeah
me and liv would appreciate any advice
and help and we're definitely going to
do that so
anytime thank you cool thank you
you